the flash actor Grant Gustin has spoken
about the decision to recast the role
for the movie version where perks of
being a wallflower star Ezra Miller will
play the fast footed Barry Allen I'm
Lucy and welcome to this multiverse
GameSpot news update costumes popularity
in the role of the flash has led some
fans and fellow actors to suggest that
he should have been cast in the film
which is due for release in 2018 however
in a statement on Twitter Dustin has
stressed that while he would have loved
to play the part
he's fully supported the decision to
cast Miller he wrote what I have liked
to play Barry Allen in the film sure I
love this character and it has changed
my life and making movies in TV is
something I hope to be fortunate enough
to do for the rest of my life I fully
support Ezra Miller as Barry Allen at
the flash on the feature side of DC's
I've never met the guy but I think he's
a fantastic and interesting actor I like
some tweets from fans expressing their
support of me and said they would have
enjoyed seeing me in the movie nothing
is anyone bashing Ezra I can't wait to
see all the DC movies that are slated
for the upcoming years I am a fan and it
will be awesome so a you team Gustin or
team miller let me know in the comments
box below or come find me on twitter i'm
on earth 42 at Lisa James games all the
latest make sure you keep a game spot
[Music]